[Music]
players all over the world have
struggled to earn the Grandmaster title
which players will earn a norm which
players will go home with the prize
welcome to the 2018 st. Louis norm
Congress
hello chess fans and welcome back to st.
Louis for the first ever named 2018 st.
Louis norm Congress my name is Ben Simon
and I'm joined alongside Grandmaster
Josh Frieda L Josh thanks for joining us
a great time for the next six days we
have plenty of rounds of action to bring
to you we have two fields a Grand Master
norm field and an International Master
norm field and the whole purpose of this
event is to get people on the road to
getting their titles their chests
doctorates if you will Josh there's a
lot of confusion as far as how does one
become a Grand Master tell us about your
journey toward the title well I
certainly went up from the bottom my
first ever rating was actually 868 so I
started pretty much as low as it goes
slowly got up there um I played I got my
I am norms in a variety of places but I
remember making the I am title fairly at
a normal level like I would make my nose
pretty steadily the Grandmaster title
was quite a challenge I made my first
two norms in 2005 and then it took me
three years to make my third norm and I
came close a bunch of tournaments but a
lot of the times I find you need a
little bit of luck you need to play the
right people there were times when I
didn't play enough foreign players and I
didn't get mine own for that reason
luckily for these players that's not
going to be a problem but you need to
play really well have a little bit of
luck and eventually persistence will get
you there well you said it for these
players won't be a problem because it is
a round-robin all play all the
tournament's that you earned your norms
in were they anything like what we're
gonna see here for the next week mostly
not I made my norms in sort of an
unusual way I made two of my Grand
Master norms actually in the US
Championships and I made one of my I am
norms there and part of the reason is
because in the US Championships you
actually waive there were foreign
requirements because it's such a strong
event but but I'd find that that's kind
of unusual most players don't really
make their
that way most of them do make them in
events like this just because they don't
have to worry about playing the right
people they don't have to worry about
other aspects like US Championships
you're not thinking about norms right I
just happen to make them but this event
is a little bit different and honestly
if you play well in an event like this
it just is much easier because you don't
to worry about getting the requirements
you just play chess and if you get a
good enough performance you're there you
made a good point about the national
championships is every national
championship that way where you can to
my knowledge yes if you make a Norman a
national championship there's no foreign
requirement but almost every other event
you have to play a certain amount of
foreign players and that's one of the
challenges of running an event like this
as I'm sure you know absolutely we're
gonna talk to the organizer later on in
this show and this is we're gonna hold
your hand out there in chess world
because there have been people who have
been playing chess for years and they
still are having trouble figuring out
the system of norms people come into the
Chess Club all the time and they say how
does one become a grandmaster and it's
not a simple answer because it's not a
simple task so the people who are in
this tournament will be tasked with
quite a lot let's take a look at the
roster for our grandmaster norm section
it's our top section the most lucrative
here and we see the mini Federation's
involved now this does have to be an
international tournament we cannot just
have international norms required and
awarded partly awarded here in the US
and an all-american tournament we've got
to have different flags that people are
playing under now in this GM event we
have four grandmasters instead of the
three that you typically see and that
are required pablo of iran so of mark
Parag wa grandmaster actress genre from
right here in st. Louis and also from
st. Louis Grandmaster Danish Boros and
then look at the contenders here all the
International masters and the woman
grandmasters at the bottom here they
have quite the hill to climb
Josh thoughts on this field I really
like this field we were talking about US
Championships earlier which is always a
great event to follow but one of the
thing the only knock I would ever have
on it is that we
almost all the players it's very rare
we'll get a newbie maybe one maybe to
this event we have so many players who
I've never seen before and to me that
makes the event really exciting we have
the woman's gonna master from Greece we
have you know the run stove I haven't
seen too much play in the u.s. harmik
ooh love and there are just so many
people who are new and I'd like to see
them play people were familiar with like
Akshay Chandra and Tata and Danish Boros
just to see what happens and to me
that's one of the interesting things
about these events we've had norm
tournaments here for years of a Chess
Club under different names this is the
first time he calls the norm Congress I
love that name by the way but yeah these
tournaments are where you really get to
be introduced to the stars I don't want
to be grandiose but the stars of
tomorrow right the chess players that
we're going to know for years to come
especially around here maybe in st.
Louis as well so it is exciting to meet
these new players exactly and some of
them end up attending school in st.
Louis if they like it here if they get
picked up by one of the universities so
if you like one of these players you
might get the chance to see them play
more a lot of recruitment happen a lot
of recruitment happens in it again to me
at least it's it's very exciting because
this is not something which used to
happen all that often so it's really
exciting to have that here that is
something I actually want to ask you
about how the the rarity of these norms
tournaments I know one player drops out
the whole thing is an enormity of it
anymore
it's very very fragile Norman's are a
special breed because it's not like a
big open tournament where say you lose a
few games or like ah I hate chess I hate
life I want to withdraw and go to the
Bahamas you can't do that during a
normal event you're required to play all
the games because if you would draw no
one can get an enormous you pointed out
so everyone's stuck which means that if
you're having a rough event your own
three everyone's gonna try to beat up on
you for the rest of the event and it's a
rough experience I'm sure almost all
just what does I've been there at one
point in their life now the two big
fields we've already taken a look at the
top one let's take a look at the
International Master norm field for this
event
field number two now we will have three
international masters in this field they
are kind of like gate
jeepers kind of the four grandmasters we
saw before and then we have feed a
masters and national master national
master is a title awarded by the United
States Chess Federation or US chess
Justin Wang who came up really big at
the last Norma vent we had here I
believe you got first place and then of
course national master Aaron Burr Vince
key as well a lot of new players here as
well and Josh they say that chess is a
young person's game but there is one
player in the Xindi that's going to
challenge that yes tencel target is 51
years old very experienced VJ master I
actually know him because I played him
once and I actually also played his
sudden ADA interpret who's one of the
top juniors in the country for his age
so it's kind of a chess playing family
and they're very friendly guy I look
forward to seeing how he does he doesn't
play that often but between 51 and there
are some real kids in this field Justin
Wang is only 12 years old and he's
already pretty strong so it's a little
frightening I don't know how these guys
are actually national masters because
their feed a ratings are high enough to
be feeding masters they're over 2,300 so
I think it's just a matter of you know
formality for them to be feeding masters
they're not really just national master
indeed and now in this tournament we
have a pretty simple format to
understand we have the two player I'm
sorry the two field 10 player round
robins all play all so it's this is not
a Swiss system this is a very simple
system to follow in fact you can go
online right now and see the pairings
for every round on u.s. chess champs
calm the games are one time control game
in 90 minutes with a 30 second delay
from move one thirty second increment
thirty second increment making sure
because if you don't get that extra time
it's a much shorter time control pardon
me thirty second agreement indeed 30
second decrement that is a big deal that
time will be added to your clock with
each move and as for the schedule if
you're on chess 24 in the u.s. chess
champs right now you'll see there's no
games going on we haven't begun the
first round this is kind of like a
pre-show the schedule is as follows
tonight we will have the very first
round for both fields both fields play
the same schedule at 5 p.m. central all
these
or central rounds two and three will be
tomorrow at 11 a.m. and 5 p.m.
rounds 4 and 5 will be Saturday at 11
a.m. and 5 p.m. round 6 & 7 will be
Sunday at 11 a.m. at 5 p.m. and then
rounds 8 & 9 have their own days round 8
will be on Monday the 12th at 11 a.m.
and round 9 will be Tuesday the 13th at
11 a.m. and I can tell you that that lot
those last two rounds can be a bit of a
minefield mentally cuz I've done a
schedule like this before and you play
two rounds a day which is pretty tough
to do you can be a long day if you play
to long games you play all these games
or two games a day then you play one
game and then you relax right you think
you're done but you have another game
the next day and when the schedule
changes I find that that's where people
can get it thrown off some people don't
don't react as well even though they get
a game off they actually sometimes will
play worse and now house game because of
that so it's something for the players
to be wary of maybe it's just me but I
find that that's actually a challenge
how hard is it to play in two of these
rounds per day I would say that well I
think the players are fortunate you guys
chose a really good time control of 90
in 30 second increment I'm a little bit
old-school in that I like slightly
longer time controls for one game at a
tournament but when it's two games a day
you do not want to be sitting at the
board twelve hours in one day then you
have to choose between sleeping and
eating it's just not a pleasant
experience so that gives you a little
bit of time it makes it easier but I'll
tell you if say you're defending some
long end game for five hours which I've
done my fair share of and then you have
to play another game that day an hour of
two hours later it's a long day and you
have to make sure you're in good shape
your energy reserves are there and I'll
tell you at the end of the tournament
the person who's had a lot of those
games they're gonna be more tired than
the people who have played a little bit
shorter and speaking of energy levels a
lot of the international players are
residing in the United States but I'm
going to have to check about which ones
were actually flying from different time
zones because you know jet lag like oh
for sure an issue there
yeah if someone's flying from Uzbekistan
like camera cool others that's gonna be
pretty rough up there just fine Yin
yesterday I
no if that's actually the case but
that's certainly going to be an
additional challenge and probably some
of the st. Louis locals will have a
slight advantage in the first round
maybe the first two rounds well we'll
see these are professional players and
they're used to and speaking of
professional players yeah there's gonna
be money involved if we didn't mention
that yet let's take a look at the prizes
here for the top section first of all
Josh take a listen to this now if you
finish sixth through tenth place the
bottom five spots you get $600 $700 for
fifth $800 for fourth $1000 for third
1500 for second and $2,000 for first
place those are pretty healthy prizes I
should say especially for a normal
tournament when I was playing mine on
Florence if I wanted to play a
round-robin like this I would usually
have to pay $300 or $400 fly myself in
do all of this and if you don't come out
with the norm you just lose lots of
money and you're very depressed
so the fact that they're providing these
prizes for everyone helping them out
with their expenses a little bit these
players
they're lucky I'm just gonna say it
these players are very fortunate and you
know I'm actually happy that this is
available now because you're gonna you
know what this is going to encourage
more chess players more people are going
to become grandmasters and international
masters but of course I hope they at
least have to work for it because I'd
like to think that to become a Grand
Master you know not that easy for sure
and of course with the second field they
also have their prize fund a very
healthy one at that for the
International master norm field the
bottom five spots will receive $400
fifth place will get five hundred fourth
place 600 third place 700 second place
$1,000 and first place pretty impressive
$1,200 so these players sometimes are
not even they don't they're not even
thinking of the price but they really
are thinking about those points they're
thinking about the wins definitely not
so let's take a look tonight at 5 p.m.
we have our first rep let's take a look
at the pairings for the GM norm section
this is a this is pretty interesting now
look we don't know
one's even so far okay in the upcoming
rounds we'll see who is the most
important to win we might get into a
situation where eventually down the line
no one can norm and now we're simply
looking at who's gonna make first place
but as we're looking at these players
here Josh why don't we have a scene
before what are your thoughts on this
Perry I I mean it's easy to say but I
actually really like almost all these
pairings I would say that camera cool up
I've never really seen play and John
Bartholomew I've played against since we
were teenagers so I know him quite well
so again I like to see people I really
know play people I don't know that well
at all
so lucky do against Advaita Patel Adi
Patel I've seen Adi play a few times but
I don't know much about him and of
course and so Loki do I barely know it
all Danish and Fateha I both know pretty
well but I'm always looking forward to
that game they both have interesting
styles so I think that could be a good
one
sometimes when you see two grandmasters
play in a GM Norma vent it can be
slightly lame sometimes they're not that
ambitious because they already have
their norms they're just kind of playing
to knock out other people or you know
for whatever reason maybe financially
but these are both players who I don't
think will have that attitude they're
both gonna probably want to play wanna
fight so that could also be a good game
so really I don't think and good image
against her own self also you know very
interesting game to watch so again I
don't think you have a bad game among
which always is a good thing now I'm
looking at right there the fourth
pairing action up Chandra and the other
in the double grand master game yeah I
think they're gonna fight in that
they're not gonna go for an early girl
what do you think about you never really
know it really depends when I was in
these situations especially the first
round you usually don't you know back
off too much the first time you want to
get a head start I can tell you that
when you're trying to win a tournament
or make a norm if that first round
really sets the tone if you play a nice
first round game and win that first
round it sets the tone for the rest of
the event whereas if you do really
ballet that first round or don't really
fight too much it can sometimes affect
you adversely for the rest of the event
and I'd say it's not a good idea but
again
ock shots a young player he's trying to
get some good gains
and you know parado as a fighting player
very interesting player I just don't see
that being a lame game at all so I would
say we're gonna see five good fights
we've got interesting players we got
fighting players in that first field but
also we've got a lot of charismatic
players in that field like I'm looking
at half the field I'm like I can't wait
to have them down here for interviews
because they're very well-spoken
individuals in the chess world you know
the more well-spoken the more marketable
as in life let's take a look at the I M
norm field the pairings for tonight
starting at 5:00 p.m. Central and also
now you'll take a look at the three
boards in the middle but they have the
International Masters Louise Torres sir
game at Cinco and Joel Manawa and then
of course the up-and-comers who were
trying to take them down and get those
points what do you think of this field
Josh again I don't think there's too
much that there's not to like Justin
weighing of course very exciting because
he's just he's so young and so strong
already that you you're interested to
see like is he gonna start knocking off
these I am sorry is he gonna struggle a
little bit a lot of it depends on form
and how well the IMS are playing but
Cinco is by far the highest rated player
in the event and it'll be interesting to
see if he just dominates the field or
whether he struggles against these
up-and-coming players he places Canadian
Chiyu in the first round and Josh colas
against Joe Benoa Josh colas is out
rated but at the same time he's been
almost 2400 so he's been to that level
where Joel is so I think that could also
be and he has the white pieces I think
that could also be quite a game and one
thing we have talked about is where
everyone stands with the norms that they
already have and you mentioned Josh Cola
is not meeting the reigning requirement
as of yet for the International Master
norm you have to achieve a 2400 rating
live at any time once you have it
doesn't matter if you go underneath it
again you need to achieve that along
with the norms to get the title merger
Josh colas has two international master
norms so he's looking for his third and
also he has one Grand Master norm so
very impressive there for Josh Graham
master norm does count toward you
so he's basically set forth at norms he
just needs to hit 2400 exactly there you
go
and he got very close a couple years ago
but he didn't quite touch and now he has
a long way to go but if he can pick up
the forum he showed in 2016
I think he'll for sure get there I would
imagine it's mathematically impossible
this go-round to meet the rating if he
went nine I know he would have a vague
chance for probably not so I would say
not this event but it doesn't mean that
he's still not chasing more norms why
not pick up a norm you know right and
you can tell I would say players for
example let's take frettin a good friend
of mine thought of Abraham Yan in the
Grandmaster Section right she has three
international master norms I think she
actually has more than three however
said at least three I don't even know
how many I probably four or five to be
quite honest
but her rating is you know lower 2200
that's been higher twenty five hundreds
so what that shows about a player is
that she can perform extremely strong
and this is true of anyone who has all
their norms but not the rating but
they're usually not consistent enough
they don't show consistent results they
might play really well and really badly
and not make that rating requirement
whereas let's say they make a Rainey
requirement but don't have the norms and
I believe there's at least one or two
players who are like that that usually
means they're very consistent players
but they don't have those breakout
results those really they don't go on a
tear and make those norms so for
everyone the challenge is a little bit
different I personally kind of made them
around the same time so I was just
volatile enough and just solid enough to
kind of escape the line but for most
people it's one or the other that they
struggle with the rating or the norms
now sometimes whenever I want to get
back to more just general norm talking
when we're not in specific norm
tournaments where we don't have the
perfect field to round-robin when you're
in the bigger events do you know when
you're gonna your possibility of making
a normal you get close or is it just
kind of a pleasant surprise afterwards
like oh yeah I got a norm too I would
say it depends on the person for me I
really cared about my norms for a while
and then I actually when I you know I
went to of years three years almost
without making a ground
stern or Milan stuck at two norms and I
just kind of stopped thinking about her
and I actually played better and I made
my norm when I wasn't thinking about my
norm at all until the very end of the
tournament in that US Championship in
2008 so for me it was kind of better to
not do that but everyone has their own
things some people have either likes for
example some of the kids have parents
who are calculating - the exact point
the whole tournament
some people just kind of go with the
flow but I'd say when you're chasing a
norm it's it's quite a feeling I
actually miss it a little bit it's nice
having the title and not worrying about
it but at the same time I miss that
extra motivation and I think that a lot
of these players are definitely counting
those points and really seeing if
they're gonna make it and indeed the big
question is if not every player who
makes it above 2,000 will become a
grandmaster of course this is a very
selective bunch only a few can excel I
know many local players who have become
stuck at feed a master or the like and
they're not going to see the i.m title
just because you're older doesn't mean
it's unattainable however it becomes
less likely so it's easier to do it when
when you're younger I use the word
easier but like it is it's more
attainable but we have a lot of stats in
front of us you keep seeing us looking
down perhaps because there's a lot to
look at the reigning and requirement of
2,400 live for an international master
norm the rating requirement of 2500
minimum for Grandmaster Norman and
that's not for the norms that's for the
title requirements for norms you need to
usually outperform the base rating
terminology I confess I used to do
believe me it took me a long time to get
it down Allah is only because I chased
it relentlessly for many years that I
kind of memorized it and for all I know
if it I could change it and then I'll
begin again but now I don't have to care
now we're talking with the organizers
the arbiter is about all this stuff
yes alongside the three norms you need
the rating requirement and I want to
talk with our guest coming in here soon
Richard pointer about the points
required because in some cases they're
different player two player it depends
on the average rating of the
combined so let's take a look at one of
our good partners in this event chess 24
you know they're one of the best
presenters of chess in the entire world
when it comes to the digital realm and
certainly our partners in u.s. chess
champs calm when we come back we're
going to be talking with the organizer
of this tournament the man who brought
the players in Richard W pointer we'll
be right back here from st. Louis
[Music]
question on Twitter from dem s I should
not have pronounced that that was a bit
of a champion for those of you who are
new to chess it might look like ba3 is
an illegal move here because white
advances pawn to square is not one but
it still is something we call hustle and
you can do that you have to do it
instantly you can't wait for a move I
could say thinking in seven Kim G - and
now try because I'll play for against
Lawrence and now he's going to play
something against me which we discussed
the playing during the course of my
steak yeah he told me this is that d5
this was what I was kind of hoping for
because now I think we finally know who
Lawrence this is not how it works
certainly will be much much more fun if
chess actually work like this I don't
think it does
well maybe it does well that's me
regretting what I just said how did I
get from there to here is a little bit
beyond me and what's worse I will never
hear the end of it my quality of life
has just gone downhill tremendous me
because I'm actually sharing the office
with the guy
[Music]
you
and we're back here in st. Louis hello
welcome back to the 2018 st. Louis norm
Congress pre-show you might say I'm Ben
Simon joined with my special guests in
this time in the very first special
guests of this campaign the organizer of
the spine tournament Richard W pointer
Richard thank you for joining me thank
you for having me I know that you are
big fan of the camera I thank you very
much for coming on sure thank you
no no really I've been wanting to talk
to Richard for a long time because he's
a really interesting guy and these two
fields were his doing he's been
stressing over this tournament he's been
making it as great as possible and the
players I know are happy because he has
helped him out in this regard this is a
really international event Richard and
how how tough were easy was it to put
this thing together to make it just
absolutely perfect so this particular
tournament was a little bit more
difficult than normal I didn't have a
lot of time to put it together just
about a month so normally I have two
months to work on this to get everything
in order maybe see some of the they're
not quite mistakes but strange oddities
of this tournament because of the time
frame that I had to organize it you end
up getting players that might you know
be the fourth GM in a GM section which
is not normal well how many times did
you just get out the pencil and paper
like you're calculating math or stuff I
mean a spreadsheet or whatever just to
make sure that everything is just so
because there's got to be an average
rating right correct so I'm doing a lot
of work on fides website looking up
basically ratings that are published
let's say for January then you have to
recalculate because these are February
ratings so I'm recalculating
on the first of the month to make sure I
know the norm number for each player you
can't even lock it in from know you can
so you know players can let's say you're
aiming for six points for your average
norm performance well you know some
players they're rating could go down and
if they go down far enough they've
effectively changed the norm number to
maybe six and a half so the it can
maybe not be as locked in as you would
hope now I'm looking at the
International master norm section and
all the players are in the same range
and that is and besides the
International masters themselves the
other players who are looking for them
they're in the same rating range and so
their goal for the points they have to
finish six points out of a possible nine
correct and they will get in a national
master norm so the GM section isn't
quite as simple yes it's different
you'll notice the average rating is
about twenty four seventy in that
section but for each individual player
their opponents average rating can vary
wildly so if you're one of the lower
rated players in the GM section you're
gonna have a lower norm number so for
example I believe Tata has a six point
norm whereas somebody like garbage has a
six and a half point right and also yeah
we have a hammer cool of six-and-a-half
gurevich six and a half Patel six and a
half Bartholomew six and a half those
are what those players are trying to
achieve and then Seoul Aikido and Albert
ami and the female players who happen to
be the last two seeds are looking at six
points because they have essentially the
tougher field of correct right and also
both of them can play for it I am norm I
understand exactly so it's just about
your performance against the field it
doesn't matter if it's named a GM
section that that really doesn't affect
the the waify de calcul that's just how
we organize correct yeah okay so Richard
a lot of these players are
internationally based do you have any
language barriers how do you get with
some of these players we've ever heard
of before
so it's great working here at the Chess
Club because you can have players reach
out to you you know we get a whole bunch
of emails throughout the year saying
we'd love to play in one of these
tournaments and the more we kind of
publicize these and broadcast them we
end up getting a lot more enthusiasm
right now we're organizing two of these
types of turnes per year along with the
four classics which are
higher level tournaments so a lot of
interest it's actually getting easier I
think to organize these tournaments as
more people express interest and the
word gets out that oh it's great to play
here in st. Louis we try to make the
conditions as you know great as possible
so did you come up with norm Congress I
did there was a tournament here in st.
Louis many tournaments actually called
the st. Louis chess congress or
something similar to that I just think
it's a interesting name and since we're
the chess capital the United States
according to the US Senate should call
at least one of our tournaments to
Congress I like it because to me it's
it's a real throwback and seems like
silly you know the US championship of
the 19th century you know the US chess
congress and there are still plenty of
tournaments called congress in the
nation but i thought it was pretty
interesting Richard what are you doing
after this no so as an organizer what's
kind of interesting duties are kind of
separated so an arbiter is in charge of
making sure that the tournament
functions from a rules perspective but
the organizers job is really to make
sure that the players are accommodated
you know if they have special dietary
requests or housing needs or even if
they want to go take a tour around town
on a half-off day or something like this
it's my job to make sure that I answer
those questions and help them you know
fulfill their needs so really I'll be
kind of working over the next six days
to make sure everything runs smoothly on
that that I'd we've got a couple hours
until round one starts are all the
players in town I believe they are it
was a little worrying today I looked at
the sheet of four check-ins and some of
the names hadn't been checked off that
were expected last night but you never
know but you do never know I mean it the
organisers job is to make sure they all
show up so they have all arrived and
that should be a good first round well
Richard alongside the chief TD ia Mike
comer
in the WT arbiter international arbiter
that's what ia stands for also Tony rich
those two men will be running this thing
Richard pointer the organizer thank you
for joining me thank you for having me
absolutely and we hope to talk to some
of the additionally some of the names
who have made this tournament possible
coming up in the next few days all right
let's take our final break on our
pre-show and when we come back Josh
Frieda I will give our final thoughts
going into today's first round a moment
comes in chess when you need to test
yourself at a different level chess 24
premium offers the tools that you need
to reach your maximum potential from
hundreds of interactive video lessons to
becoming part of the chess 24 community
you can analyze with friends or coach
your students live you get twenty four
by seven coverage of chest news and
events access to premium analysis and
commentary and the chance to interact
with grandmasters and other top players
and coaches get it bashed from the best
and even challenge them to a battle be
the best just player you can be it's
time to level up your game with just 24
Premium Membership
[Music]
[Music]
be surprised be intrigued be delighted
the world chess Hall of Fame in st.
Louis is nothing you'd expect and
everything you love three galleries
highlight the history culture and
creativity behind the game explore chess
in ways you never imagined it's a
one-of-a-kind cultural institution where
rare artifacts and world-class
art play together the world chess Hall
of Fame mind art experience
hello and welcome back to our final
segment here for the preview show of the
2018 st. Louis norm Congress the GM and
IM norm event I'm Ben Simon along with
Grand Master Josh Burdell who will be
the man analyzing the games in the
upcoming days telling you where the good
moves were and where the bad moves were
Josh any final thoughts on this
tournament in these fields well one of
the things I forgot to mention about the
GM fill which I found very interesting
was that the field can kind of be
divided into two sections those about 30
years old maybe give or take a year or
two and those who are 20 years old or a
bit under so it's gonna kind of be a
battle of generations in addition to
AIIMS versed GM's and other things like
that so I thought that's kind of an
interesting subplot to that particular
event it is interesting subplot there
there is a divide there that's a very
good point we look forward to bringing
this event to you yeah through Tuesday
the 13th of February
remember there are nine rounds each day
you will get at least one round but
sometimes two so tonight at 5:00 p.m. we
will have round number one just a couple
hours from now tomorrow we'll have two
rounds Saturday will have two rounds
Sunday will have two rounds and then on
Monday we will have the penultimate
round eight and then on Tuesday the
final round nine and even if the norms
are out of reach at that point this
tournament doesn't end we're going to
the end you will be playing the players
will be playing for up to over a
thousand dollars up to two thousand
dollars in prize money so this is
definitely not the only story here the
dorms there are many stories here the
Battle of the GP ages the battle for the
prize money and the battle to advance to
get your doctorate of chess well
speaking a doctorates even in the second
section we have one with tencel turbot
maybe the cardiologist he is card he's a
cardiologist so he's gonna be fighting
for all the cardiologists and people
over 40 years old because he's the only
one so he's gonna be fighting his own
battle and I'm gonna be rooting for him
personally I'll tell you that he may be
an emotional favorite so good actually
the reason why I like him and I haven't
met the guy he's because I sent out an
email survey to some of these players
and he went above and beyond giving me
some details I love this guy I need to
meet him we need to talk to him so this
show was produced by the chess club's
world's greatest B team Isaac's rants
the graphics and audio man our technical
director is danny Machuca for a
grandmaster Josh Bedell my name is Ben
Simon we'll see you tomorrow and every
day through the 13th at 2:00 p.m. so
until then so long from the
show-me-state don't miss it
[Music]
you